[inaudible].
Hello.
How's it work?
This is a cool place.
So not a bad spot.
We have our own real estate kind of.
Yeah,
you're the real estate guy,
let's say guide.
It's exciting to enter through.
Uh,
the other real estate guy.
I love doing deals with Google people.
It's great.
You always know they can close.
Right?
Which is really important to me.
Well,
it's in a big,
it's a big talent pool.
We have 10,000 Googlers in New York,
so I know,
I don't,
I don't think you've sold to all of them yet.
No,
not yet.
Not yet.
Yeah.
Yet that is the goal.
So why don't we start in the book.
You talked about your childhood,
childhood growing up opposite to the guy you see on TV.
And I thought that'd be a great place to start.
Great.
Uh,
yeah.
You know,
a lot of people,
most people know me from million dollar listing New York,
which started in 2012.
I was cast on it in 2010.
How I got cast on that as a totally,
it's like book number two.
Um,
I,
but I wasn't,
you know,
I think I was kind of like the opposite person when I was a little kid.
Right.
Like the Anti Salesperson,
which is a big push for me to write the book.
Like it didn't necessarily write it for great salespeople out there who are
crushing it and at the top of their class.
Right.
I mean,
I think those people should also get it,
but I really wrote it for the people who were like me,
who were super shy,
introverted.
I moved eight times before I hit fourth grade.
Like I was really overweight.
I had really bad self confidence.
I just liked theater.
My parents made me play every single sport known to man,
hoping I would get over it.
Um,
you know,
uh,
it was,
you know,
my whole family is in finance,
everyone's very business oriented and I just want it to do like theater and come
to New York after college.
Uh,
which no one approved of whatsoever.
Um,
and then I ran out of money.
Right.
I mean,
that's like kind of classic story.
I moved here in 2006.
I went to Hamilton College in upstate New York.
I was a theater major,
also English lit because my parents made me and um,
and I gave myself two years on like summer savings and it lasted me two years
and I ran out of money and didn't know what to do.
And it was either go home to Colorado and painted fence for the rest of my life
or which was an actual summer job.
I had painting wood fence.
There's a lot of it in Colorado.
Um,
or figure out something.
I had a friend of mine who was like,
listen,
don't be a waiter.
Don't be a bartender.
Get your real estate license markets insane.
This was the summer of 2008.
Your timing was impeccable.
Yeah.
I could not tell the future.
Um,
and uh,
as a real estate guy for Lehman brothers when it went under,
yeah.
I know what your first day of work was like.
So you started the day Lehman collapsed.
Yeah.
September 15th.
2008.
It's a big,
which for a lot of people was a really awful day for me.
It was one of those.
Yeah.
Um,
and that's that,
you know,
it's tough.
I had a lot of friends who worked at Lehman.
Um,
you know,
and,
but for me,
I had no money.
Like I,
I was either a figure out this real estate thing or go home to Colorado and I
had gotten my real estate license.
It didn't really all make sense to me yet what was really happening in the
world.
Because if you're living in New York City,
trying to be an actor,
you're not watching CNBC every day and you have no money so you don't watch the
markets,
you don't really know.
And I just thought real estate was the hardest thing in the history of the
world.
I just figured that everyone in New York City have lost their jobs all the time.
You know,
those first two years,
I mean every client I would get,
they would lose their job in 2008 and 2009 and it wouldn't be able to afford
apartments.
So in hindsight,
it was the absolute best time for me to start because every broker was getting
out of the business cause they all called the end of the world.
Um,
and for me I was there to kind of like pick up the pieces and just sort of
figured out as I went.
So you talk about Improv as a training ground.
Yeah.
So spend a minute on that.
Most important training I ever did to be a real estate agent was taking Improv
classes in high school and college.
And I still make everyone who works for me taking prof,
um,
because it is,
it was important that you can do as a salesperson is learn how to listen and
learn how to act on your feet.
And those are two things that a lot of people think they have,
but it is,
it's a real muscle,
you know,
it to be able to think on your feet and never used the word no is a really kind
of hard thing to do because most people will say,
um,
like right.
Or let me think.
That's like,
that's how we grow up.
But to be able to say yes and over and over and over to whatever your client is
saying,
but was like my really,
really helped me a lot when I first started.
Um,
and the people have taken Improv,
you know what it is.
Okay.
So we have work to do.
It's important especially because,
yeah,
exactly.
Because it,
it really,
it's really scary,
especially as you get older.
And I was just fortunate that I took it when I was younger and then thought it
was fun.
But once you get older,
you're more self aware and you don't like to embarrass yourself.
And so that's actually when it's more fun cause it's just ridiculous to watch
people.
Um,
and you should just go watch improv classes cause cause they're funny,
they have them everywhere and they're like five bucks or 10 bucks.
Um,
and you just create situations and in sales that's what you're doing.
You're negotiating people's emotions and there's no script for that.
You're figuring it out as you go.
And that's what Improv is,
has taught me and taught the team.
I think the other big observation you have is that,
uh,
in real estate sales and TV,
the first impressions are literally everything.
Yeah.
And if you're not careful,
they're also your last impression.
Right.
So give an example of where that,
that moment occurred,
where you were at risk of the last impression.
Um,
probably when I met you and I didn't look up from my phone,
so I,
uh,
it was just in the middle of something while he was eating raisin brand as well,
so that you guys have food here,
which is great.
I'm a real estate broker.
Every time I see food and like cool cause it's got to,
got to survive,
you know,
like just take it really simply.
Right.
I didn't write the book for real estate agents.
I mean my life is as a real estate agent,
but it really wrote it for like anyone who just wants to do better and do more.
Whether they're selling,
you know,
digital advertising or they're selling themselves to their boss to get a bigger
promotion,
or they're trying to convince their kids to go to bed on time,
you know,
or they're trying to pay down student debt.
Like I wrote it for,
for everybody.
But put yourself in the shoes,
like you're walking into a store and someone comes up to you and they say,
or what do people typically say?
Like,
Hey,
can I help you with anything?
And what do you say?
No thanks.
Right?
For the most part you say,
no thanks because you don't really want to be bothered.
And it's a salesperson and it's like gross,
like,
no,
it's fine.
I got it.
I'm looking at shoes over here,
right?
And then they'll say like,
Hey,
okay,
let me know if you need anything.
And then they walk away.
That is every sales person in every store in the entire world.
So you have to remember that every client interaction you have is just like
you'd be making a friend or meeting like a future boyfriend or girlfriend.
I mean,
could you imagine going into a bar and like tapping on someone's shoulder
randomly and saying,
hey,
let me know if you need anything.
Like how do you think that would go?
You could get super lucky and they could say,
actually I do need something and then that's a one off deal,
but for the most part everyone's going to say,
you were with me.
Okay,
so for the most part people are going to say,
no,
I'm okay.
Or that's weird.
Right?
So that's a bad first impression,
which is now the last impression you're going to have that salesperson,
right?
A different way is to introduce yourself.
Okay.
Introduce yourself and start with something super simple,
like a compliment.
Right?
Most people think about the clothes they're putting on or think about their
ridiculous mustache that they grew out to try to sell books or your story or you
know something,
right?
Or if they have a kid with them,
you compliment the kids.
Something small just to get them to smile and to start a positive interaction.
Swear to you.
It works every time I've gone into stores like to buy a pair of socks,
someone has come up to me,
introduced themselves and complimented me on something and I've left with like a
canoe.
And maybe that's just cause I'm gullible,
but it also,
it works,
right?
You're,
you're building that trust in that first impression and you have less than 20
seconds to do it.
Oftentimes you have less than 10 seconds,
right?
Every relationship,
even with your best friend or your partner started with like a ten second
introduction.
And with the people you know that you're friendly with,
it works.
Other people that didn't work.
So I talk a lot about how to make it work more.
And then how about at the other end of the spectrum,
the indecisive client,
because we all have indecisive bosses and associates.
How do you manage the indecisive client?
Okay,
good question.
Um,
there's,
I broke down as much as I could.
You know how there's like the six stages of grief and then like the types of
tornadoes.
Like I always,
when I got into the business really kind of thought of sales like the six stages
of selling,
like what emotional clients go through because they go through their grieving
period,
like their denial period.
They're excited,
period.
And you have to walk them through all those steps.
And the best salespeople are the ones who can anticipate it like an er doctor,
like they know like when this next emotional phase is going to hit so you can
prepare how your conversation is going to lead into that moment.
Kind of like a psychologist,
right?
But people who are indecisive or people who are insecure about the decision that
they're going to make any way.
Like at the end of the day,
a lot of indecisive people we know they end up making a decision.
They're just really self conscious or insecure about their intelligence or
something.
And you have to help them get comfortable and figure out how to get there.
And a lot of it is just laying out options.
So kind of the way I just talked to you about first impressions and it could
have been super boring,
but I made it relative by talking about dating and a bar.
And then people laugh and they're like,
oh,
that is kind of the same way.
Oh,
interesting.
Same thing with people who are indecisive,
you know,
it's figuring out a way to make it relatable to them.
And like if you have a client or a boss or somebody,
you figured out what they like to do personally.
So you track them on social media,
let's say.
And you figure out that they really liked cats.
Okay.
Or they really like golf or they're really into the jets.
I don't know.
Something like that.
You try to,
without telling them that you internet stock them,
you figure out in your conversation with them how to make whatever the situation
is you're talking about it relatable to something they really like.
Like,
you know,
this is,
I understand you want to take your time,
but if Sam Darnold had taken his time,
you know,
in his first game out,
might not have won that first game.
Huh.
And then that guy is going to be like,
dude,
you're a jets fan.
Like I mean,
sure,
yeah,
no,
I am.
Oh,
crazy.
Yeah.
Anyway,
the real reason I don't want to do this is because of x,
y,
and z because now it's on a personal level now that they about something that
really like,
plus you made it relatable and it's just how you present that information versus
that salesperson who just says,
can I help you with anything?
No.
Okay.
Let me know if you need anything.
Great.
That's most people.
And so you,
you talk about the four tenants of work,
the four ws.
Yeah.
So it's the why the work you're wall and the win.
Spend a little time on the wall.
Um,
so when I first got into the business,
I had no boss.
I had no mentor.
I went to a brokerage called nest seekers,
which is still there and there's like 800 agents there now.
When I was there,
it was like 20 above Burger Heaven on 49th and Madison and didn't really have a
mentor.
No one told me what to do all the direction.
I was given was find apartments that are in other cities that look cool,
post them on craigslist,
use really good pricing,
meet people at Starbucks,
take them to other apartments.
Okay.
That was the New York City rental broker way of life up until like 2009.
Um,
and so I didn't want to do that.
That seems super weird to me.
And I wanted to figure out how I was going to actually build a sales business
and how I was going to build like a sales career and not just be someone who
lived deal by deal by deal or somebody who woke up a year from now and said,
wow,
last year was great,
but it was also the same exact kind of year that I had the year before and the
year before and the year before.
And I looked at all the top performers in the business and all the top
companies,
right?
Like all the fortune 500 companies.
And you know,
they all had really,
really strong through lines to how they figured out like what they were working
against.
Like what?
Like what's Google's kind of through line,
right?
They're trying to make the Internet a better place,
more searchable,
all that stuff.
Something like that.
Right?
You guys would know better than me.
Anybody want to cover the mission?
Yeah,
I'm sure it's out there.
Um,
and so for me,
I wanted to figure out what,
like what's that thing that I'm running against as much as possible.
And as an individual salesperson,
it has to be something personal.
So for me,
the wall,
um,
is that moment in the summer of 2008 when my debit card was declined at food
emporium on 59th street,
buying Tofu of all things,
uh,
and I didn't know what to do and I really freaked out and I just took my card
and ran out and jumped on the subway and sat next to some random person and just
tried to hold back tears because that was the moment I was like,
this New York thing sucks.
I hate it.
I don't like it.
I don't want to be here.
I just want to go home.
Um,
and then I decided to get into real estate and that's the moment I run from
every single day.
And it sounds kind of crazy,
but everyone needs to have that wall,
right?
Maybe you work at Google,
but before this you did another job that you really didn't like and you don't
want to go back to that job because this is now super awesome.
Do you have free cereal?
Like that other job is your wall or maybe you just love New York so much and you
don't want to move home to Colorado to paint fence or whatever your story is
like that then is your wall.
Or maybe you were bullied in high school like I was and you want to show those
people who the boss,
that's your wall.
So for me it was figuring out that moment on that subway and I'll run as far
away from that moment for the rest of my life as possible.
And the others are really just trying to get clear with your goals.
Like companies have goals,
companies have mission statements,
why shouldn't individual people have the same thing?
Why should an individual salespeople have the same thing?
You should also have what your,
your when is right.
That's kind of the mission statement.
So for me,
my wind,
but doing so likes her hand for Bravo and then writing this book.
I think that I'll always do real estate,
but I really have found that my passion is helping other people increased the
quality of their lives through selling.
Because selling is like the greatest career you could have because one will ever
take it away from you and you will never be unemployed,
especially in a volatile work market the way we have it now.
Like I right now am unemployed.
I don't get a w two I get a 10 99 I eat what I kill every single day.
I'm a very successful unemployed,
employed person and I,
that's the greatest thing because I get,
I get fired every week.
Clients fire me all the time just because that's what happens in this business.
But it's okay because I have other clients and they make up for it.
I don't ever want to put myself in a position where everything in my life could
be held by one place.
And as a salesperson,
you have that amazing talent to take that anywhere,
whether it's here or somewhere else.
So in the show you parlay your real estate sales into supporting and helping
people who are in different stages of their life and their state of kind of,
yeah.
Where,
how do you pick those candidates and what's your greatest success in terms of
individuals?
They,
uh,
there was a casting process that Bravo did this end up casting notices
everywhere.
Um,
and then just got lots of submissions from people.
It was hard to cast because a lot of people,
cause they'll show only made sense if I was working with really bad salespeople
who are literally about to lose their jobs and then the business had to agree to
go on camera.
Like their families had to agree to go on camera.
The bosses had to agree to go on camera.
So there's like a whole process to it.
So it was hard to find people that wanted to put themselves out there like that.
Um,
but I think the most successful person,
I don't know if you've watched the show,
but there is kind of too,
there was one guy who sold wine.
Um,
his name was Tim in Millbrook and he let me know that he was a recovering
addict.
Like when I first met him,
which was really tough cause he sold wine.
But that was all he knew how to do.
Like he,
he got addicted to heroin outside Phoenix when he was 13 math when he was 14,
tried to kill himself when he was 15,
cleaned himself up and sent himself into the army when he,
I guess was 17,
did two tours to Afghanistan and then came back clean,
ready to go.
Wouldn't go back home to Phoenix because that's where all those triggers were.
Tried to get a job in New York,
couldn't get one.
Um,
put himself through the New York Culinary Institute,
but then couldn't get a job as a chef.
And then a friend said,
listen,
I've got this winery in Millbrook.
Come work with me.
Sell wine.
Had no idea what selling was.
Thoughts.
Salespeople were the worst people in the world,
uh,
like legitimately.
And,
um,
and I helped him understand that selling isn't taking,
selling isn't being greedy.
Selling isn't like,
come on,
come on.
Just do this,
do this,
like selling is assuring.
It's not convincing.
Selling is walking people through options so that they picked the best one for
them and an option that they otherwise would have picked anyway.
But they're just going to do it with you and not do it online.
Are they going to do it with you now and not do it later.
Right.
Um,
and so that was a good one for me working with him because he had a,
like we secretly flew his parents in from and he hadn't seen them since he got
back from Afghanistan.
Like the whole thing was crazy million dollar listing.
Very different show.
Yes.
Yeah.
So in,
in a recent interview you said that one of your core principles is for
sustaining key relationships is actually knowing how to give before you take
anything.
Yeah.
And I think you've kind of spoke to that a minute ago,
but if you,
not that we're off camera,
but if you were speaking off camera,
um,
versus on camera,
what would you like people to know about the reality reality TV that they may
not know?
Million or listening takes us nine months to film an entire season.
Um,
and an air is really,
really quickly.
So there's a lot of stuff behind the scenes that you don't see just because it's
boring TV.
Unfortunately.
Like I always want to show like the deal stuff,
the closing costs,
the taxes,
you know,
all like the,
like the crazy stuff that really drives us crazy.
It's hard TV to show and there's three of us on the show.
It's an hour show,
which means there's 44 minutes or 16 minutes of commercials,
which means each of us get like 11 to 12 minutes of airtime and it has to be cut
down into just those big moments,
get listing,
figure out how to sell it,
don't sell it,
maybe sell it a little personal item done.
Um,
but there's so much more that goes into it,
right?
Like I start my day very,
very early and I tried to start in the office to prep for the day ahead and then
I end incredibly late to clean up the previous day and then prep for my day
ahead.
Like my day starts the night before.
And that was an important thing that I figured out when I first got into the
business.
Otherwise,
like you wake up and you're scattered and you look at your calendar and like,
all right,
what do I have to do today?
But by then like your day is already be gone and it's like you're late to the
race.
Um,
but yeah,
reality TV is fun.
You know,
it's been good for me.
I mean I got onto that show by just like convincing them I was the greatest real
estate broker in the history of the world and I knew that they were from La and
they didn't know anything and they were like,
are you sure?
And I was like,
yes,
I am sure.
Like really?
Cause then all these other brokers that were interviewing,
they don't know who you are.
And I'm like,
really?
It's just cause they're jelly.
Right.
And they slowly whittled it down and whittled it down.
And I got to the point where I was like,
just getting friends to help me with things and like trying to like,
it was like call,
call me 50 times a day,
call me,
call me.
Cause I'm with the cameras right now and they're still interviewing like 15
other people and like,
what am I calling you for?
So they call me,
they'll be like,
Hey Ryan,
you told me that I'd be like,
yeah,
no deals closing,
I'll call you right back.
Boom.
And the producers were like,
this is the greatest real estate broker we've ever seen.
Um,
I've been doing it now for eight years,
so I'm comfortable putting that out there,
but,
and then got cast on it.
And then that was like,
uh,
oh,
all right.
Now I got to figure this out.
My whole life has been just saying yes to everything and then having to just
figure it out.
So,
which is a great lead into,
you talked about when it's time to let the deal go and how to feel.
Yeah,
I think that,
uh,
I mean when I first started as a salesperson,
I didn't let any deal go right because I didn't really have a whole lot of
choice.
And some of my first clients were people like definitely should have let go.
But it's,
it's a time benefit analysis,
right?
You're never going to close somebody who has a great personal relationship with
someone else who does what you do.
Like I as many apartments as that would love to sell.
There are always going to be sellers who grew up with a real estate broker today
or who are married to a real estate broker or you know,
who have some kind of personal connection.
Those are people that I,
I need to really look at the time that I would put into that deal and probably
decide,
you know what,
I'm going to lead them for other people.
It's okay,
right?
I'll live,
I'll go find other people.
Um,
and then there are people too who are just completely irrational,
unreasonable.
And you know those people you have to cut loose when they don't really move up
that emotional kind of ladder that I talk about in the book.
Like if they just stay on hysteric or you know,
overemotional or if they're mean like there's a lot of people in the world who
are really mean and are belittling,
especially in my business,
I don't know how it is for you guys,
but like it is really easy to be mean to a real estate agent.
Right?
And it's easy to take out all your frustration on that,
which is fine and I'm totally okay with it and I get yelled at every day.
But if that's there,
like status quo,
then those are people that I need to let go just to say the negative energy.
It's going to affect me in all of my other deals and I don't want to bring that
into the rest of my life.
So in the book you talk about client x,
which may not have been your hardest deal you've ever closed,
but it might be.
So it spend a minute on that because I think it's such an amazing story.
Oh Man.
In the book,
I have to call them client acts for fear of my life.
Um,
and I say he's from Atlantis also for fear of my life.
so client x was a guy who cold emailed me when I first got into the business and
said he'd like to invest money into the New York City real estate market.
Um,
would I be able to help him?
he would use real cash dollars and would need bank account help.
Okay.
Uh,
and I totally replied and I was like,
absolutely,
I can help you with bank account help and absolutely,
we take cash,
money,
dollars and,
uh,
how much are you looking to spend?
And he was like less than 10 million.
And I was doing like $2,000 a month convertible,
three rentals in the West village to Jessica,
Jessica and her friend Jessica at the time.
So like,
I,
you know,
uh,
who were coming from Murray Hill with their guarantor father.
And so a guy who all of a sudden just told me $10 million for over the Internet.
I was like,
boom,
Jackpot.
This is New York City real estate.
And I got super excited and then he wanted to talk on the phone.
So he had to,
he was like a real person sort of a,
and I just sent him a bunch of listings because I didn't know.
And he picked one at 45 west 67th street,
apartment 15 ABC.
And I remember every address and he said,
uh,
I would like that one make offer 8 million.
And it was asking 8.5 million.
And I was just like,
holy mother of I just $8 million offer.
This is what it is.
This is,
I am now the greatest real estate broker in the history of the world.
Uh,
I asked him to send me a proof of funds and he sent me a DHL.
Right?
I remember that.
He sent me a DHL the next day with like a photo of an accountant with a letter
that legitimate and he said,
Mr x does not commit to things that he does not commit to.
That was his proof of funds.
And I was totally okay with it.
I was like,
this looks good to me.
Cash money dollars in New York City.
Uh,
and we negotiated this deal over the Internet for eight point $3 million.
And I was immediately thinking about the commission in my head and thinking
about how long I would be able to stay in my apartment with all that rent money
and everything and craziness and taxes didn't even come into the conversation.
Um,
and then he disappeared off the face of the earth for like a month and he had
had a contract and I'd introduce them to an attorney.
He just never replied ever again.
Um,
but I followed up like every day because this was my one big fish.
No one else in their life had ever talked to me about spending that much money
in an apartment.
And then he eventually writes back like a month later.
And says,
sorry,
it's been a little busy.
I'm like,
okay,
no problem.
Uh,
and he actually signed the contract and then he has to send a deposit and then
the deposit never comes.
And now I've got the seller freaking out,
other brokers going crazy and like months go by.
So we have to sign contract and it doesn't mean anything.
And then,
uh,
the attorney's telling me that what's basically happening is that this person
takes a signed contract and this happens all the time in New York City and they
shop it around the world and they say,
listen,
this is this apartment.
It's probably worth 10 million.
I've got it for 8.3.
Give me $20,000 coming in on it with me.
And they'll sell the contract over and over and over to unsuspecting victims and
they'll steal people's money.
So it's a scam.
Um,
and so then I was like,
you know what?
This business sucks.
I don't want to do this anymore.
And I'm the best broker ever.
But now I'm the worst one because I'm involved in some money laundering scam
between some crazy person from Atlantis.
Can't believe I responded to this guy and I think it was like two months go by
and then the attorney calls me and says,
you're not going to believe this.
I just got an $830,000 deposit from Bank of Atlantis and I almost had a heart
attack.
I was like,
are we in a contract?
He's like,
yeah,
you're in contract.
It's like holy mother of God,
eight point $3 million for an apartment I sold over the Internet.
Um,
and then there's this thing in New York City called a board package,
right?
You have to do an application and then there's this thing called closing,
which you have to do.
Uh,
and he vanished off the face of the earth,
stopped responding to everything like six months.
Right?
So imagine signing a contract for something and then disappearing for six
months.
Okay.
So now you've got different attorneys looking to sue everybody,
but who do you go after?
Right now it's just about keeping that deposit and holding the deposit back.
But I followed up,
it's my whole life is followup.
I wrote about in the book,
there's a whole chapter,
it's really invigorating.
Okay.
I will follow up with you until the day that you die.
I followed up non stop,
just checking in,
just saying,
Hey,
I know we're probably getting those documents together,
still need to do this application.
And then I had some genius idea too because I looked him up initially and I'd
seen that like he might be attached to this house that looked expensive in
Paris.
Okay.
Um,
and so I sent him this email that said,
hey,
in total desperation I'll be in Paris tomorrow.
If you want to meet in person,
we can go through the documents.
And he wrote back in like one minute after six months of nothing and said,
sure,
10:00 PM and gave me a location.
And now I'm like,
well shit,
the biggest deal in my whole life that I still haven't done.
Now we've got to figure out how to do this.
And so I use all the money I had and uh,
got an Aer Lingus flight through Dublin.
Uh,
and then I think it took Ryan Air,
which was super fitting for me to Paris to try to find this magical person.
All the while,
like kind of telling my parents what I was up to,
kind of not because it's a little bit sketchy and probably really dangerous.
Uh,
and then 10:00 PM rolled by and the guy doesn't show up.
I'm like crying and my begets,
and uh,
I think it was like 1:00 AM cause I had nowhere to go and I didn't plan on
getting a hotel or anything.
I just thought I'd like wing it,
you know,
and then just go right back to the airport.
Um,
and then what am he shows up with like a line of people.
So I know he's real.
Um,
and all he really cared about was getting me drunk and he just wanted to watch
me drink.
Um,
and I was the opposite of who he was in every way,
shape and form.
Um,
and I drank a significant amount of Tequila and he likes,
sort of looked at the papers a little bit.
I got them to sign two things and I would just fill out the rest.
So I took it as a win.
Went back to New York City,
a very sick and then he had to come close and he disappeared off the face of the
earth again.
But at least now I knew that he was a real person.
And then to make a long story short,
even though as long like he randomly one day again,
months later,
so this is like a year long process says I'm in New York City,
I'd like to close like,
are you crazy?
It's,
it's like 11:30 AM we will,
you can't just get a closing together right?
I'll put fine,
we'll figure it out.
Because everyone was,
they were trying to sue for deposits was crazy.
It's like,
where are you?
Mandarin Oriental went up there to wait for him.
It doesn't come down on time.
Finally comes down with like 15 people in this fleet of black escalates,
pulls up outside the Mandarin Oriental completely tinted out and crazy.
The minute that happens,
I text my mom and I say goodbye.
This is again,
like the only deal I've ever done other than just like rental deals on
craigslist with people that I'm like baiting and switching.
Okay.
The New York way.
So,
uh,
we get in the car,
he's got like an espresso assistant,
totally crazy.
And I'm like,
listen,
Mandarin Oriental,
45 west 87th street's right there.
Do you want to go to the walkthrough?
I'm sure you're really excited about this apartment.
He's like,
no,
no.
We go to JFK.
Uh,
so we went to JFK and we went to the back of JFK and we pulled up,
uh,
and there was this big seven 47,
and he got outside and he bought it and he got back in the car.
And now I'm totally confused.
Now I don't really think I'm going to die now.
I'm just like,
really?
I don't know who this person is.
And then we go back into the city and he signs the papers and he closes a,
and all he cares about is taking a selfie with me for his BBM profile.
Um,
if you remember those and turns out that he prints about a billion dollars a
month.
Um,
and he's like wealthier than Kadafi and just wasn't concerned with this little
apartment and the only reason that he moved forward because he thought it was
super amusing to watch me consistently persistently follow up.
And the fact that I actually went to Paris and he knew it was bullshit.
Like he knew that I wasn't going to be in Paris.
Right.
Is one of the reasons he went through it.
And since then we've done like 300 million together.
Just as a way to diversify and move money around.
Every deal has been super painful.
Um,
and that's,
that's the power of yes and right.
That's,
and it didn't take money of mine going to Paris costs money,
but other than that,
follow up,
following up with items of value,
like staying on top of him.
Everything.
Every deal is a deal.
You're just trying to see which salesperson is going to quit first.
Right.
Just like kind of every race.
And I always equate selling to a race.
Like you wake up every day.
That's why I say ready,
set,
go all the time because my dad told me to say it every day before I leave when I
was third grade.
You know,
before I step out of the house,
before you cross over one foot ready,
set go.
Cause it sets your mindset up for running a race.
You just have no idea what kind of race you're going to run.
It's gonna be a marathon today.
It might be a sprint and that it's a marathon.
It might be hurdles and then it's like a six k you don't know.
But as long as you are prepared in that moment,
the moment you leave your house,
I'm going to run a race today.
I'm going to get when it in some way,
shape or form,
it just sets your mind to be ready to go for anything to say yes and then figure
it out.
So that's,
uh,
so before I ask the next question,
if anyone wants to line up to the mics and we'll open up for questions in a
minute,
but as a great pivot to the next question,
which is explain your get FK d um,
theory and why it's one of your most valuable secrets.
Yeah.
You're going through like the whole book right now,
Huh?
Yes.
It was a great book.
You guys.
Yeah.
So Fk d um,
again,
I was on as the world turns and got killed off.
Okay.
That's where I made the most money before getting to real estate,
other than hand modeling,
I hand modeled,
I held cell phones for a t.
And.
T they were everywhere.
By the way,
if you Google my name and hand modeling,
it's awesome.
Uh,
I held Nespresso capsules like this.
I'd have to like move the metatarsal of like my pinkie.
I'd have to get like hand massages and everything.
Um,
so that's my background into business.
So then when I got into real estate,
I didn't know.
All I knew was you post ads online,
you meet people,
you try to convince them to sell,
to buy,
to rent.
And I wasn't rich and I'm not from New York City and I don't go to the
synagogue.
So like I,
I'm like shit out of luck.
Um,
my nicest clothes wear cowboy boots and khaki pants,
right?
And so when I made that decision of,
you know what this,
I'm going to figure this out and I'm going to move against the grain here in New
York City and I'm going to be the best broker ever going to figure out how I'm
going to do it.
I didn't know how to structure my day.
And that was the one thing that really like would get me depressed and like
would really kind of hurt me was,
okay,
I have one appointment at 3:00 PM.
What do I do the rest of the day?
Like,
what do I do at nine?
What do I do?
I cold call people.
Do I ask people for help?
Like do I post ads?
Like what,
uh,
how do I structure my day?
And I think people are creatures of habit.
So I looked at big companies.
I said,
okay,
every big company out there that's super successful has a CEO,
a CFO,
and a COO.
I have no idea what they do.
But for me I think it's important that part of my day,
I have a CEO brain on to that for me was my finder time cause I had looked at
CEOs and I said they find business for the company to work on.
Right.
That's what they do.
They prospect business for the company to work on.
Yes,
they deal with problems and all that stuff,
but CEOs really like they are there to move the ship forward and give the
company a lot of stuff to work on.
Okay.
So from eight to 10:00 AM every day I'm going to put finder and those are my
hours were everyday.
Now I'm booked from eight to 10:00 AM I'm not waking up with nothing to do until
3:00 PM eight to 10 it's my finder hour or two when I just focused on Ryan
[inaudible] real estate.com like my own little personal business and how I'm
going to sell more,
grow more and brainstorm my career.
And it's amazing if you just spend some time every day and just think about
yourself that way and about your business and how you're going to do better,
you will come up with ideas that you never would have come up with just because
your brain is capable of things that you just,
you just don't know.
Right.
Um,
keeper was the CFO time,
so it was like 12 to one and I would just think about all the money I didn't
have and if I had like 10 bucks to spend that day,
you know,
I would budget because I knew it was important to invest back in your business.
So I would say,
okay,
$10 that gets me how many stamps?
And I would send out letters to one building that day or it's going to get me an
extra latte and I'm going to go to Starbucks and I'm going to try to find
pregnant women and sell them apartments because they need more space.
Right?
Like that's my thing today.
Um,
true story.
So one of my first clients were pregnant and they needed more space.
It's a real thing.
Uh,
and then my COO time was my dewar time.
So Fk d,
that was like the rest of my day.
That's when you put all of that stuff in the action.
So that's when I was stamping things.
That's what I was going to Starbucks.
That's what I was doing,
the appointments.
And I still do that to this day.
Um,
now the times are shifted.
Now I spend a lot more of my time in that finder time period than I do in the
keeper and do her.
Um,
but it's important to think about yourself as an entrepreneur and as an
independent contractor and as a salesperson,
as somebody who runs a large company,
whether it's true or it's not,
the only way it will be true eventually is if you think to make it so.
Yeah.
Great.
Go to the audience.
He was here first.
All right,
let's do,
okay.
So a million dollar listing,
you have,
uh,
you know,
a lot of,
one on one interactions.
Now obviously it's edited and perhaps that's not,
you know,
how the rest of your day goes.
But,
um,
now you have a team of,
you know,
several hundred brokers.
How do you manage them?
Do try and spend one on one time with each of them?
Do you have lieutenants or other people?
Like what's,
how do you structure it?
Uh,
the team is 62,
not yet at a hundred.
Okay.
Um,
but it's,
but thank you.
Uh,
I,
I tried to spend as much time with them as I possibly can.
Right.
They're all really busy and everyone's different,
right?
I,
I let all of them know that I'm there for them all day long.
There are certain people on my team who need a meeting with me every single
week.
There's certain people on my team who need to talk to me every day.
There's other people on my team would do really well who I have to go after for
updates.
Right.
And that's just sort of the way they work and so I'm not a big fan of creating
rules and then making team members stick by them.
I want people to be able to move flexibly to be as successful as they possibly
can be and then they just have to set those expectations for themselves.
So like at the end of the year we'll have like a goal meeting and my goal
meeting,
I don't create numbers.
I have them tell me how much money they want to make next year and they have to
make the number.
It's not me.
Right.
If they say like $5 we have to move it up,
but they have to set the number and then we back into that how much they have to
sell to get there.
That's now their base salary.
Everything else they sell above that is bonus.
If they sell under the number they just said they want to sell and they don't
come talk to me by June or July saying,
listen,
the years terrible New York City real estate market has fallen to the four,
something like that,
then they can't be with me.
Um,
but I talk to my team more than I talk to any other client and I really view
teams as like football teams.
You know,
I'm awful at every sport known to men,
but I do know how football teams work and it's important that everyone can be
their own individual rock star and be successful and be great at what they do.
But you're not all going to win unless you're able to play well together and
work together and talk to each other and figure it out as obstacles come at you
like the New York jets,
you know?
I hope that answers the question.
Okay.
First,
thank you for being here.
Thanks.
I think the yes and figure it out mentality.
Mindset
very much resonates with most of us in this room because we invented a category
20 years ago.
And I think in some ways we're still doing that.
Yeah.
Um,
personal story.
I met Frederick in Starbucks like eight years ago and I've been here for a
while.
While he was just kidding,
he seemed to be a very different person eight years ago then he is on the show
today.
Yeah.
So is it kind of expecting him to be a Douche and he wasn't?
He was very nice.
Um,
but I've been in sales for 20 years and I recounted a story to him that I had,
I had used a line that I,
I heard on the show on a client.
Oh Wow.
And it worked.
And the line was,
I was working with a very big telecommunications company in the line was if you
have $7 million,
you have $8 billion close,
$8 million,
$8 million deal.
I was like,
oh,
that to you guys,
so thank you.
Yeah.
Um,
I have moved out of sales after 20 years and I'm now on a team that's
responsible for training 10,000 sellers at Google.
Oh,
his cell.
And we're at this inflection point between being a trusted advisor and being a
competitive seller because it's a very fine balance.
What do you think are the most important attributes of a seller as they balance
being a trusted advisor and a competitive seller?
Okay.
Endurance,
empathy and enthusiasm.
Ooh,
three e's.
I like that a letter.
It's in the book.
Okay.
I'm buying it.
It's a,
it's like you didn't just teed me up for that,
but you did sort of,
it's,
it's what I look for in every salesperson that I hire.
Um,
and I do that by,
uh,
like they have to have enthusiasm,
right?
So I asked them to tell me the story about the greatest day of your life.
And if they tell me like,
well,
Christmas when I was 10 was great.
They cannot work with me.
Right?
Um,
they have to have empathy.
So,
um,
I tell them that I asked him to tell me about the worst day they've ever had in
their life and if they're like my dog died,
that cannot work with me because the ability to be enthusiastic with the clients
and the ability to empathize with a client are,
that's the only way you get sales done.
There will always be sales that just come down to numbers.
Like there will always be those conversations.
That was a great,
that's your base salary.
Like those,
those are the deals that are just going to happen because the numbers make sense
in the product's good.
Everything else is empathy,
enthusiasm,
right.
Energy,
education,
all words that start with E.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great.
Anybody else?
Oh no,
he's going to the bathroom sites.
Love you too.
Oh,
there we go.
Hello.
Hi.
I'm so,
I'll use this opportunity cause I definitely don't have the money to ever work
with you directly.
So if I was an investor and looking for an area in New York,
yeah.
Where I'd like we see the most upside in the next five to 10 years,
what would you recommend?
I do Bushwick.
Okay.
Yep.
Uh,
Bushwick.
Bedstuy right.
I think that bedstuy is already kind of getting expensive.
Um,
and people are already trying to go there.
I think that Bushwick,
anyone who buys in Bushwick today,
we'll do incredibly well in five years.
Um,
and I,
yeah,
super simple.
You have any listings?
Yes.
Listen,
I am here to sell homes to all of you.
Like,
let's not,
I don't want to meet any of,
I'm going to remember all of you.
I don't want to meet any of you on the street or in Starbucks ever.
And you're like,
oh,
I just bought a house.
But I didn't know if like maybe it was too small for you or I had this friend
know like I am here for a purpose and it's a cell.
All of you homes or help you rent homes.
Okay.
Does someone make sure that that's super clear.
So on the left side,
we're going to line up for people that want to buy out her apartment on the
right side.
We're doing the book signing.
Yes.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Right.
And one question,
like given the variety in your background,
how much in the like in your career has it been about what you wanted to do
versus who you want to be?
Whoa,
you Googlers.
Um,
I made a decision when I was younger and I think it's,
this is important because I talked to a lot of people who have this problem.
They want to be a really great x,
right?
They want to like you have a night,
like you want to grow up to be like me,
like an actor.
Right?
Or you want to grow up to be a successful banker,
successful engineer or something.
And then when that doesn't happen,
it's like a brick wall to the face and life is over.
Right.
And then they go off and do something else.
Like there's a lot of people who run into those situations where their whole
life they wanted to do something cause they wanted to beat that person.
Um,
but for me,
I,
uh,
whether it sounds crazy or not,
like I always just,
I want it to be successful.
Like I wanted to squeeze as much out of life as possible because I knew life was
short and I knew that I didn't want to leave potential on the floor.
Like I didn't want to be in the cemetery and be one of those people who's like,
wow,
if he'd only just done x,
y,
and Z,
we might know that he did that.
Right.
And so I chose success first,
career second.
Um,
and that's an important thing to put out there because a lot of people think it
sounds weird and crazy and that it doesn't make sense.
But if you choose career first,
I see I could've done that with acting and I wouldn't be here today and I'd
still live in my 300 square foot apartment at 38 west 31st street,
sharing a bathroom with 17 people.
Not that that's a bad thing.
Um,
it's an honorable thing maybe,
but it's,
it wasn't what I wanted for myself and I wanted to have a better quality of life
because again,
life is super short.
Um,
so I chose success first,
career second.
And I think when people do that,
then when things don't work out,
like when I was killed off on as the world turns,
right.
Um,
I think it wasn't this brick wall that I was hitting where my life was over and
I had to move home.
It was okay,
so that career didn't work out.
Let's see what else works and real estate sounds awful.
And real estate brokers have a worst people ever.
But you know what,
maybe I'll try to change that and figure it out and do it in a different way.
And does that answer your question?
Definitely.
Thank you.
Okay,
got it.
All right.
Sometimes I just start going off in my head.
Oh,
thank you so much for being here.
Big Fan.
No problem.
I was wondering if you could maybe share about your cast mates on the show.
We've had some friendships,
not friendships.
Are you,
would you consider them friends now and maybe something like unexpected about,
um,
the other brokers who appear on the show.
Um,
listen,
I have been on the show from the beginning with Frederick and so we have a love
hate relationship.
Like we are,
because we're competitors,
we go after the same projects,
the same listings all the time.
And it took us a while to figure out,
but I think in the last couple of years,
maybe it's just because we're getting older,
like we just realize that we're a lot more alike than we thought.
Um,
I think I'm better,
but
it's,
you know,
we're,
we're both equally competitive and we want to do as best as we possibly can.
Um,
but we're also like in this crazy thing together,
you know,
like,
it's like that show,
like at least when it first came out,
like it was watched by 25 million people around the world.
And it's like crazy to us,
you know,
like I get,
we get fan mail from Korea and Iran,
like deaf.
How would those people would ever know that I'm a real estate broker is beyond
me and I would never be able to afford that type of advertising.
Um,
and so listen,
Frederick and I are friendly now.
Um,
and,
but we're still very competitive.
Um,
I haven't talked to Michael Lorber and forever he was season one.
Luis,
I talked to a lot more now than I have in a long time and he's actually back in
the city and haven't told anyone yet.
But I'll tell people at 3:00 PM on Instagram,
he's going to moderate my book signing at Barnes and noble on Thursday and it's
me,
his first public appearance in like two years.
Um,
and I've always been close to Luis and he was at my wedding and everything.
And then Steve is,
Steve is knew Steve Super Pretty.
Um,
and so,
yeah,
but Steve's great.
See you see a total sweetheart.
Um,
he's great at what he does.
He's a lot more sensitive than people probably think.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know if I have any,
did you try and get him to join your team?
I did.
We filmed,
so stay filmed a scene with me after town crumbled,
um,
me trying to get them to come to the team and figure that out because I thought
it would work.
You know,
like with Frederick it wouldn't work.
But with Steve I thought we could probably do more together than separate.
And he thought about it.
And then Corcoran just made him a really great offer,
and then they just cut that whole scene.
And that's reality TV.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yes.
So on behalf of the 10,000 potential sales that are in this building and
building,
thank you,
been great having,
you definitely will have people lining up to,
to have you sign their book.
You can clearly follow Ryan on Instagram,
Facebook,
Twitter,
and his Youtube Channel,
which highlights a day in the life of Ryan,
which is actually interesting to watch as well.
So good.
Thank you.
[inaudible].